it's healthy to grow our own strengths
and rather than be intimidated by the
strengths of others
having worthy rivals instead of
competitors competitors are
other players we set out to beat but the
problem with
that is there's no finish line there are
companies that are desperately clinging
to their old business models
but this this marketplace you know if
you're not willing to pivot
the marketplace will put you out of
business wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you're capable of more
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn
how to motivate the unmotivated with
simon sinek
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one grow your strength
human beings we can't help ourselves but
compare ourselves to others
and comparison is is the deadliest thing
we can do to ourselves
because we will always come up short
it'll all it does is exaggerate all of
our insecurities
it's okay to enjoy other people's
success but you
let them live their lives and you live
your life oh and by the way
they're curating their social media
that's not really their life
um and so you're making decisions based
on how you feel based on their curated
things i know i've talked to so many
millennials i know somebody who's out of
work
really depressed and yet she goes and
does all these things so she has the
appearance of this amazing successful
life
and and so you met now she may be making
those decisions based on what her
friends
who knows what sort of weird twisted
exaggerated you know
circle of of depression this is forming
so
go back to the rules of the infinite
game your friends are there to admire
your friends are there to say god that
i'm so happy for them what are they
doing that i can learn from
i'll give you an example so we're all we
can all fall into this trap so
you know in my business uh authors and
speakers and folks like us we're all
comparing ourselves to each other and
sometimes it can get
silly and competitive and there was you
know sometimes i go on amazon and check
the rankings of
my books to see that there's that i
still have a job
and and now and then there was this one
author
who i hated for no reason he's very
smart his work's incredibly good he's
incredibly well respected
i respect him but i hate him and i would
check
the rankings of his books and when i was
ahead i'd be like yes
and when he was ahead of like right it
would drive me crazy i had this weird
abstract competition
same thing right social media happened
to be amazon rankings right
and i would check in all the time i'd
always check in mine his mind his nobody
else just mine and his
anyway we were uh i was at an event and
we were interviewed together on the same
stage
and the interviewer decided to let us in
introduce each other
so i went first i had to introduce him
and this is what i said i looked at him
and i said uh
you make me very insecure
i said because all of your strengths
are all of my weaknesses and every time
i see you do well
it just reminds me what i'm bad at
that's how i opened up he
he turned to me and he said funny i feel
the same way about you
and now we love each other because i
realized
that he's really good at what i'm bad at
so
by me getting to know him and really
learning to love him
i'm realizing i'm getting better at
those things and i'm taking more pride
in the things that i'm good at rather
thinking rather than thinking i have to
be good at everything he's good at
right so that that it's it's healthy to
grow
our own strengths and rather than be
intimidated by the strengths of others
rule number two be vulnerable okay so
let's be crystal clear
um uh what vulnerability is
actually requires strength to do it
requires unbelievable strength to
to to come into a meeting and say
i'm struggling with this covet thing um
i'm not sleeping and
and i and i and i fear that i'm not
there for you guys
and i'm not sure i'm not sure what to do
i mean that requires unbelievable
strength to be able to say that to
someone
and so and so i let us call it strength
to be vulnerable
not weakness to be vulnerable um if if
um if we are receiving feedback that
we're not being vulnerable
then maybe it's true and maybe um our
team
is is what they're really saying is
please lead us because we feel that
you're not leading us i mean i think
that's an indication
and if you don't know how to do it um
ask for
ask for help call people up and say i
know i need to do this and i don't even
know the first thing to do
and start small you don't have to go
crazy
and being vulnerable doesn't mean uh you
know
like you're talking to your therapist in
the in a meeting it doesn't mean
letting it all out it doesn't mean
broadcasting everything
um uh what it means is being honest
about the daily machinations
um it's totally fine for a leader to say
um i don't know what the future looks
like
um i have a vision um i think i know
what it takes to get there
but i know i can't do it alone i know
it's going to take all of us
um i think a very very easy dipping your
toe into vulnerability
uh uh is coveted you know
um to say i've never gone through
anything like this before
and i there's a side of me that's kind
of figuring it out as i go along and i
need your help and i need your patience
um you know to dip your it's an amazing
opportunity covert has has offered
because
nobody thinks you're weak saying i don't
know what's gonna happen
uh you they think you're being honest um
so i think you you need to start
experimenting
um and you need someone preferably in
the company who who you trust who can
give you guidance
in other words to call them up
afterwards and say how did that go
you know you know you need spies um to
say
is that being well received was i okay
yeah um and even to say out loud
i don't know how to do this i'm not good
at this i've i've never
i used to think vulnerability was stupid
and weak and i'm learning
that it's it's an expression of strength
and i'm going to experiment with it
simply saying that is a step to
being vulnerable to simply say i don't
know how to be vulnerable to the team
but i want to try because i know it's
important that's where i would recommend
starting
rule number three don't give up when i
was writing
leaders eat last um
i got to the point where i couldn't do
it it was
it was too difficult i i couldn't i
couldn't organize all the information it
was just too complicated i
i couldn't do it and i'd been trying for
months i've probably missed multiple
deadlines
and i was sitting at my computer and i
decided that i had to give up i couldn't
do it
and so i got up and went for a walk and
i was literally planning
my exit um i was going through the steps
i was going through the checklist of
quitting
i knew that i have to give my advance
back to the publisher because
technically i'm in breach
um i knew that i would be humiliated
but i was preparing myself for it and
that i would get over it
i was also rationalizing that it was
okay to quit i told myself
there are thousands ten thousand books
published every single year
no one will miss this one book
and i literally went through the steps
to prepare myself
for what i had to do to quit i'm not
sure why i did this
but i called a friend of mine who at the
time was in the air for special forces
and i don't even think i said hello when
he picked up the phone
i simply asked the question what do you
do when you can't complete
the mission and as is his habit
he just started telling me a story he
was a
helicopter pilot and they had a mission
in afghanistan
that was um a suicide mission all the
intelligence
showed that the air defenses were just
too great
and none of them were gonna come out
alive um
and it wasn't gonna be one of those kill
hitler missions where
we're all gonna die but we'll kill
hitler this is like we're all going to
die
and the mission will also fail and he
was preparing his helicopter
for this mission and his wingmen turned
him and said
what do we do we've got wives we've got
kids
do we refuse to go what do we do
and my friend turned him and he said
this is what we signed up for
we go he asked me he said
is this book more or less powerful than
start with why i said the
research has impacted me greater it's
it's more powerful he says all right i'm
going to tell you a funny story
before i met you i'd become
disillusioned with the air force and i
was going to quit
and i found this cookie little book
called start with why and it completely
re-inspired me
and i decided to stay and i'm a better
leader now than i than i was before
because of that book and if you're
saying that this book
is more powerful than the first one then
we need this book he said this is what
you signed up for
you have no choice
clearly his mission was scrapped
at the last minute the underlying
message of
this is what you signed up for you have
no choice wasn't a mean message the
underlying message was
and i will be here with you the
underlying message was no matter what
you can call me at any time i've got
your back.
and that's the important part i turned
around went back to my desk and finished
writing that book
not that night i mean it took me months
but
but i never thought of quitting ever
again as soon as i knew
that someone was there someone had my
someone had my back rule number four be
the idiot the reality is i'm an idiot
like and i'm not being i'm not being
flip about it like i don't understand
very complicated things
and so i ask a lot of questions so that
the person who's telling me something
complicated
who's talking in terms as if i
understand them sure finance or
neuroscience i don't know what you're
talking about right and i ask enough
questions just so that i understand it
so is what you're saying this no that's
what i'm saying well what are you so
i i we're most i mean i'll give you a
perfect example so
a long time ago i had a client they were
a uh public company
and uh they brought me on
um to do some work for them but the
the they invited me to sit in on a
meeting
from the consultant that they had hired
um
and so all the c-level executives and me
and this consultant was giving a
presentation about something wrong this
is junior marketing
this is when i had my little marketing
company and every all the ce level
executives sitting there nodding and
taking notes on the on the you know on
the powerpoint that they had printed up
in front of them and i had it as with as
well and i didn't understand a freaking
word of it yeah
right i was like looking around like
yeah i'm r
and i and so i'd raise my hand and say
i'm really really sorry
i know i'm the only person in this room
without an mba but
this doesn't make sense like you say a
plus b equals c but
based on your logic a plus b equals d i
can you just say it again please i'm
really i'm really sorry to slow the
meeting down everybody
you know and you could see the
consultant getting frustrated with me
and would try and explain it again i
said i'm
so sorry and one by one all the c-level
executives
said yeah i don't understand it either
now if the idiot hadn't spoken up
yeah and said i don't understand they
all would have nodded their heads yeah
for fear of looking stupid because they
don't understand
yeah and it would have they would have
paid a lot of money for a document they
didn't understand
and they would never have used it would
have sat on a shelf um
and it's it's because i'm i'm okay being
the idiot like
that's why i'm not being flipped i'm
okay everybody in the room going ugh
because i have to ask questions until i
understand it but the reality is is once
i can get
to the point where i understand it i can
get it so simple that i understand it
and i can say it in simple terms that
means other people understand it too
yeah yeah so it's there's a lot of value
being the idiot
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days
i will send you an unlisted video the
sign says it takes up to 254 days
of consecutive action build a habit so
i'm going to be with you every step of
the way
if you want to be on for free 100 free
is the link below
go check it out i'll see you there the
skill to hold your opinions to yourself
until everyone has spoken
does two things i would rather take the
risk of walking out
knowing that i might get moved in a way
that i've never experienced before
more than just going to have a nice
night out and see something that i know
is good
successful measurement successful
recognition is not just for the steps
you take
it's not just for the effort it's that
the effort you exerted moved us
closer to where we're trying to get to
rule number five inspire people
i don't think you can motivate the
unmotivated i don't think you can
motivate people people either are
motivated or unmotivated i think you can
inspire people um
and uh and you know you can motivate
people with
sticks and carrots you know offer them
bounty or threatened punishment
and you'll get behavior that you want is
there loyalty is there love absolutely
not
usually when people are unmotivated it's
not necessarily them
it might be the situation they're in
maybe they don't belong in the culture
maybe they feel unseen or unheard maybe
they're scared maybe they're unprepared
so we we have to you know when
somebody's unmotivated let's not label
them as unmotivated first
what are the 20 other things that it
could also be
let's start there now are there some
people in the world who are unmotivated
absolutely you hired them which means
you bear some responsibility
if it's if it's time to transition them
to help them find another place where
they're going to be a better fit we
can't yell at them and call them stupid
unmotivated and push them out the door
we have to bear some responsibility we
hired them and if we made a mistake and
hired somebody who's a bad cultural fit
then we have to take care of them and
help them transition to somewhere where
they're going to be
a better fit i think that you know if we
only focus on motivating people and
that's a factor
then you're only going to get very
finite thinking an excessive amount of
motivating things like hit this number
get this bonus
you'll get a motivated employee pool
that doesn't care about about each other
might stab each other in the back
and eventually will take a better job
somewhere else we have to inspire people
we have to give them that sense of cause
and vision that their work is worth more
we have to make them feel like they
matter and feel like they're seen and
heard and understood
and what ends up happening is those
people are not only more vote motivated
and inspired but if they're offered a
better higher paying job someone else
they turn it down because it's not just
about the bonuses and the money it's
because they would rather be here with
these wonderful people
rule number six have worthy rivals what
i recognized was so often in business we
have these competitors
sometimes on our own teams that we want
to beat them we've all had the
experience where
one of our colleagues got a promotion
and we got upset we got angry
we got angry at somebody else's success
think about that for a second
why couldn't we share in the joy right
what is it about them that's being
revealed in us
that's the problem right and so having
worthy rivals
instead of competitors competitors are
other players we set out to beat
but the problem with that is there's no
finish line
and so if we're obsessed with beating
the other company
then at some point sure you're ahead in
whatever metric you chose
until when right at what expense at what
cost
uh that's not sustainable but rather the
other players inside our industry
outside our industry on our own teams we
can choose our own worthy rivals
their strengths reveal to us our
weaknesses and by having our weaknesses
reveal to us it means we have the
opportunity to grow and improve
and the infinite game at its core is
basically a game of constant improvement
and so our worthy rivals reveal to us
our weaknesses
and our opportunities to improve rule
number seven love what you do
that to me is madness everybody
the vast majority should get to wake up
and say i love my job it is a right
it is a god-given right that we should
love where we work
and we should demand it we should demand
that our leaders provide an environment
in which we want to come where we want
to care about each other where we feel
safe
to express our vulnerabilities and our
fears and our concerns that we're open
to correction and discipline and
feedback that we're not defensive
because we know that it's being given to
help us improve and grow and we want to
improve and grow
and in turn we will help others improve
and grow because when we feel safe
when we feel that our leaders
care more about us than a number
they care more about our lives
and our confidence and our joy and our
skill set more than some short-term gain
that they care more about our priorities
than the priorities of some
disinterested external constituency
then we will respond in kind and we will
offer our blood and our sweat and our
tears and we will make sacrifices of all
kinds
to see that our leaders vision is
advanced and that this company continues
to thrive
not for them for ourselves it becomes
deeply personal
it becomes something we love
contributing to i talk about it all the
time
working hard for something we don't care
about is called stress
working hard for something we love is
called passion
and i'm tired of listening to ceo saying
we only hire passionate people
what you don't even know what that means
how do you know that they're passionate
for interviewing and not passionate for
working
you know every person on the planet has
passion
right we just don't all have passion for
the same things give me something to
believe in
give me something to believe and give me
the opportunity to contribute to
something
allow me to make mistakes and try again
and you'll have passion up the wazoo and
rule number eight the last one before a
very special bonus clip is allow
positive disruption this is one thing i
got wrong
in my book which is i said that most
leaders
will either experience an existential
flex once
maybe twice sometimes never in a career
i never expected that every leader would
be facing it simultaneously
but the principles are still are still
the same whether we're all going through
it together or not
um which is it's not about the daily
flexibility of business this is profound
180 degree strategic shift
[Music]
i'll give you my favorite example um in
the late 1970s
uh apple's already a successful company
they've already come up the success of
the apple one the apple ii steve jobs is
already a famous ceo
and understand apple had a just cause
they had a
vision a very clear vision which is they
wanted to empower individuals to stand
up to incumbent
uh uh power they wanted to empower
individuals to stand up to big brother
this revolutionary spirit
and if you remember um uh that's what
they that's what they stood for right
the computer revolution they were one of
the leaders of the computer revolution
um uh and jobs and a few of his senior
executives
um as executives do went and visited
another company and they got a tour of
xerox
xerox park which is xerox's r d division
and xerox showed them something they
invented
called the graphic user interface
which allowed a computer user to click
a mouse uh and move a cursor across a
desktop
to use icons to work the computer
now this is a profound technology
because prior to that you had to learn a
computer language
so driven by the the idea that one day
an individual be able to compete against
a corporation
job jobs sees this new technology
and goes back to his team and says we
have to invest in this graphic user
interface thing he sees it as a leapfrog
technology
to advance their vision
and one of the leaders who was there
that day said we can't
we've already invested millions of
dollars and countless man-hours in a
completely different strategic direction
if we go down that path
we will blow up our own company to which
jobs
actually said better we should blow it
up than someone else
well that decision led to the macintosh
a computer user operating system
so profound that the entire software of
windows is designed to act like a
macintosh
and the reason a computer is now
household appliance
was because of their willingness to make
that profound strategic shift
and so the reason uh leaders usually
don't make
an existential flex is because they're
too afraid of the short-term losses
they're too afraid of of the disruption
even if they sometimes see it as
necessary
one of my favorite examples of a failure
uh was blockbuster
blockbuster was the only significant uh
national video rental chain uh you know
they were the 800 pound gorilla
and this uh little company called
netflix showed up
and saw the rise of the internet and the
potential for streaming in the future
the technology wasn't quite there yet
but everybody knew it was coming
but they started experimenting with an
entirely new business model called
subscription
and if you remember you could get the
dvds and keep them for as long as you
wanted
and then send them back and the ceo of
blockbuster at the time went to the
board and said i think we really need to
experiment with subscription
and the board would not allow him
because the company made twelve percent
of their revenues
from late fees they were so afraid to
give up twelve percent of revenues
that they literally committed an act of
suicide blockbuster doesn't exist and
netflix is determining the future of
television and movies now
the the they will say the internet put
them out of business nonsense they put
themselves out of business
and so we're seeing that right now in
cobit as well
there are companies that are desperately
clinging to their old business models
but
this this marketplace you know if you're
not willing to pivot
uh the marketplace will put you out of
business and so we're seeing
wonderful uh uh disruption happening
positive disruption taking advantage of
covid to make changes they see it highly
necessary
where they may not have made these
changes prior because they were just too
afraid
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
when you watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of following through that's not
enough but when you write down what time
what place and how you're going to
actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're gonna do it
it jumps to 95 percent that you will
follow through so i want that for you
believe nation i want to know your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you when my career
was just getting going
uh and i was a speaker uh
which by the way was not my chosen
career i fell into it
um uh there is a a i forgot the name of
the organization i think it's called the
meeting planners association of america
something like that where basically all
the people from all the corporations and
conferences
who hire the speakers like that's their
job they have their own conference
and so to get invited to this thing is
like
it's like american idol like yeah like
if you do well
you get a career for the rest of your
life because everyone in the room will
want to hire you for their conferences
for the rest of years
and if you if you bomb they all know who
you are and you will have no career
right like that's mm-hmm i was like
i've done this a bunch now i'm you know
i'm relaxed on stage now
you know i got this you know and like
this is one of those events that makes
every speaker nervous
and uh and it's in this cavernous
place ironically it was like the worst
venue it was like
it echoed so you'd stand on the stage
talking you could hear yourself
anyway during my talk i'm doing start
with why it's back in the early days
i got this you know done this a million
times and
don't know what happened i lost my train
of thought okay
i i know this i've been through this
from before so i went quiet
you usually find my place and then i
pick up again like i know how to do this
i've lost my train of thought before
i went quiet and nothing happened like
nothing
came into my mind i had nothing and
now i panicked and as soon as the panic
sets in
now now all rational thought disappears
and now i start sweating
and my heart starts pounding and i got
nothing i got
nothing and i look at my pad and i look
at the audience and i look at my pad and
i look at the audience
and then i turn to them and say have you
ever had that
feeling where you forget what you're
talking about
and everything collapses your hearts and
your stomach your
heart's pounding you start sweating your
hands get clammy
and sheer panic and they're all smiling
i said
i'm having that right now i said
i said and i gotta tell you it feels
fantastic i said because i do this so
much
sometimes i forget to be present and i
said right now
i feel completely alive i said i feel
totally present
and totally with this it's as much as i
is as crazy it is
this is amazing i said
okay i need someone's help can somebody
please tell me what i was just talking
about because i do not know what i was
talking about
and they all erupted in applause i got
more applause for that
than for the actual speech
but the point is the point is
is is that in every civ
in every cloud there is a silver lining
in everything that happens to us
there is goodness
[Music]
if you want some epic simon sonic
motivation check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there vision
is an internal thing right it is the
world that you want to live in
right jobs was the rebel and he always
was
against big business right